das robert-koch-institut hier in berlin
vor corona würde ich mal sagen konnte es
kaum einer jetzt kennt wohl jeder
deutsche und der ärger ums rk ii und den
instituts chef lothar wieler der reist
nicht mehr ab ja denn nun warnt ein
bundestags gutachten der ak-chef habe zu
viel macht zweig zweig + 3g 4g er kann
praktisch alleine entscheiden und wir
fragen uns warum eigentlich
er ist der kopf hinter den corona
beschränkungen rk ii bosse lothar wieler
was in den letzten wochen monaten ja
sogar in den letzten jahren vom
bundestag und rat beschlossen wird geht
über seinen schreibtisch wenn wieder
sagt zweig reicht nicht ziehen die
bundesländer nach sogar mit 2g plus über
nacht kürzt das rk ii den genesenen
status von sechs auf drei monate vilas
erklärung die immunität von genesenen
variiere alles ein bisschen an den
haaren herbeigezogen ich mache nämlich
meine arbeit und die ist
wissenschaftlich fundiert in erster
linie wo man diese wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse allerdings nachlesen kann
bleibt unklar
es gibt also ein gutachten das zeigen
soll dass lkw chef lothar wieler zu viel
macht hat dieses gutachten liegt bild
natürlich vor und darüber möchte man
sprechen mit philipp iad auf dem bild
meinungsschwenk und morgen philipp also
sag uns mal was genau steht jetzt da
drin in diesem gutachten also es ist ein
gutachten des wissenschaftlichen
dienstes des deutschen bundestages also
juristen des parlaments die im auftrag
von abgeordneten gewisse sachverhalte
prüfen und hier war eben die prüfung zur
frage war diese entscheidung den
genesenen status über nacht zu verkürzen
per mausklick des robert koch instituts
da kann es eigentlich sein dürfen die
sowas oder überschreiten die vielleicht
ihre befugnisse oder sollte ein
robert-koch-institut eine nachgeordnete
behörde die ja niemand von uns gewählt
hat überhaupt so viel einfluss haben
über unser leben und die juristen kommen
ehrlich gesagt zu einem sehr klaren
schluss und das resultat dieses
gutachtens ist
über den genesenen status sollte nicht
eine nachgeordnete behörde wie das lka
entscheiden denn der genesenen status so
schreiben dass die juristen sei von
hoher grundrechts relevanz was heißt
dass unsere grundrechte hängen ja
zurzeit an unserem info oder genesenen
status also in unserem immunität
nachweis das heißt wer entscheidet ob
jetzt jemand als geimpft oder genesen
gilt der entscheidet auch darüber ob
millionen menschen ins restaurant dürfen
ins kino dürfen ohne test bus und bahn
fahren können und so eine entscheidung
gehört eigentlich ins parlament das
müssten parlament und regierung treffen
aber es kann nicht sein dass eine
behörde die niemand von uns gewählt hat
plötzlich per mausklick über einfach
aktualisiert die website aktualisiert
und plötzlich hunderttausende millionen
menschen ihre rechte neu justieren
müssen also würdest du auch sagen lothar
wieler hat zu viel macht dass er das
eben entscheiden darf eindeutig er hat
eine macht aktuell die er nicht haben
dürfte und das zeigt jetzt das wird
jetzt ganz besonders deutlich in der
verkürzung des genesenen status ehrlich
gesagt er hat sich die macht ja nicht
selbst genommen sondern die wurde
ebenfalls verliehen die wurde ihm
verliehen vom bundestag und vom
bundesrat die haben eine verordnung
angepasst und in der verordnung wird
einfach auf das robert-koch-institut
verwiesen was so viel heißt wie wenn das
robert-koch-institut seiner meinung
verändert dann ändert sich unsere
gesetzeslage gleich mit und dass man da
muss man ganz klar sagen robert das
robert-koch-institut lothar wieler haben
eindeutig zu viel macht dann macht die
sie in unserer demokratie nicht haben
sollten weil sie eben nur eine behörde
sind die von niemandem in deutschland
gewählt wurde und wir haben
volksvertreter die für uns im parlament
sitzen diese leute sollten für uns
entscheiden über unsere grundrechte und
für unsere freiheiten und auch über
einschränkungen diese freiheiten aber
keine behörde nun liegt dieses gutachten
vor juristen haben das eindeutig
festgestellt zu viel macht bei lothar
wieler wir finden es auch nicht in
ordnung aber hat dieses gutachten denn
tatsächlich jetzt auch eine direkte
auswirkung muss lothar wieler jetzt
gehen muss er seine kompetenzen wieder
einschränken wird das irgend eine
direkte auswirkung haben auch auf leicht
auf den genesenen status nein schön wäre
es wenn man sich diese juristen auf
jeden fall wirklich genauer durchlesen
würde und wir haben das inbild heute
enthüllt und da sagt beispielsweise der
erwin rüddel an der einflussreiche
gesundheitspolitiker der cdu die macht
muss zurück ins parlament geholt werden
also es könnte sein dass das ein
nachdenkprozess anregt der beiden
parteien dazu führt dass man vielleicht
die entscheidung überdenkt und das man
bedenkt wie viel macht das robert koch
institut zur zeit hat dann noch mal dass
wir haben gewählte volksvertreter und
die sollten ihre macht nicht an
irgendwelche behörden auslagern sondern
sie dort behalten wo sie sein sollte im
parlament und vielleicht holen sie jetzt
wieder zurück aber es gibt auch noch
eine alternative denn am genesenen
status haben impfstatus hängen ja
zurzeit unsere grundrechte und wenn man
nicht zufrieden damit ist wie darüber
bestimmt wird also was das robert koch
institut auf seiner website
veröffentlicht dann kann man auch als
bundesland darauf reagieren man kann
zweig regeln beispielsweise abschaffen
und zweige plus regeln man kann also
einfach sagen man löst sich jetzt von
dieser abhängigkeit davon wer geimpft
ist und wer genesen ist man kann auch
einfach sagen omikron rauscht jetzt
sowieso durch die maßnahmen scheinen
offensichtlich nicht zu funktionieren
konzept wer kein rekord instanzen
gleichzeitig ist micro viel milder
deswegen wenn man unzufrieden ist als
ministerpräsident mit dem rkw chef
lothar wieler kann man darauf reagieren
indem man einfach zwei geschafft
ja und das lka die genesenen status über
nacht von sechs auf drei monate gekürzt
hat der fdp mann wolfgang kubicki ein
absolutes no go in unserer sendung die
richtigen fragen hat er sich ganz klar
positioniert anders sah das aber boris
palmer aber welcher der streithähne kann
sie dann überzeugen ich kann mir
wirklich nicht vorstellen dass eine
solche entscheidung für ein bundes oder
jetzt woche wird mit auswirkungen auf
millionen von menschen ohne rückkopplung
des dafür zum sales der jetzt das muss
noch geklärt werden aber dass herr
dealer oder wie auch immer in dem
einfach die internetseite ändert und wir
dann die genesener status halbieren ist
für mich schwer nachvollziehbar vor
allen dingen gehört das nicht zu seiner
kompetenz die im zweifel können
ja dass wolfgang kubicki doch recht
deutlich philipp glaubst du dass sich
bald mehr politiker auch gegen lothar
wieler auflehnen werden und sagen so das
reicht jetzt ja wir haben in den
vergangenen zwei wochen also am 14
januar ist das ja passiert hat das
robert koch institut aus dem nichts
offenbar sogar ohne karl lauterbach zu
informieren einfach den genesenen status
geändert und seitdem befindet sich beide
sowohl karl lauterbach als auch lothar
wieler wirklich in einer welle der
kritik
ministerpräsidenten haben offenbar zu
spät verstanden was sie da eigentlich
verabschiedet haben was sie beschlossen
haben im bundesrat welche macht sie
einer behörde gegeben haben ich glaube
da wird es noch sehr viel kritik geben
die frage ist wird diese kritik folgen
haben wir haben jetzt 16 jahre angela
merkel hinter uns da hat man auch
durchaus beeindrucken gesehen wie man
kritik auch einfach aussitzen kann
deswegen man schauen wie jetzt olaf
scholz darauf regiert wie karl
lauterbach darauf reagiert bislang ist
die reaktion sehr unsouverän karl
lauterbach hat gesagt naja das lief
kommunikativ vielleicht nicht so toll
aber wissenschaftlich ist das ja sehr
gut begründet die verkürzung des
gelesenen status man muss man sagen nein
das ist nicht so dem widersprechen alle
wissenschaftler alle mediziner und alle
studien die bislang veröffentlicht
wurden also das deutsche ärzteblatt
herausgegeben von der ärztekammer hat
studien gesammelt und gesagt gelesene
sind mindestens genauso lang und genauso
gut geschützt wie geimpft wie kann es
dann sein dass man nach der zweiten
impfung einen impfnachweis von neun
monaten hat und nach einer infektion
wenn ich doch besser schützt nur drei
monate das ist einfach einfach unlogisch
das ist nicht wissenschaftlich und es
besteht durchaus die chance dass das
auch konsequenzen haben wird wir werden
das auf jeden fall weiter verfolgen
vielen dank philipp potthoff
ja und jetzt schauen wir einmal auf die
aktuellen corona zahlen und dafür ist
viele jetzt am tisch aber
wir uns mal die aktuelle entwicklung
anschauen fangen wir mal an mit den
neuansteckungen da sehen wir hier unsere
kurve die zuerst kommt er ganz tief war
ein bisschen hoch gegangen und dann
jetzt am ende ziemlich steil mit mikro
nach oben geschossen es aktuell sind wir
jetzt bei 78
1318 ein neuer höchststand ist das
allerdings jetzt nicht zum glück schauen
wir mal auf die hospitalisierung
incidents dir nun eine der wichtigsten
werte ist in dieser pandemie und da
sehen wir sehr viel geld auch relativ
viel grün ein bisschen rot eben in
mecklenburg vorpommern und sachsen
anhalt insgesamt liegen wir bei
4,64 jetzt haben wir auch noch den im
monitor vorbereitet da sieht es
tatsächlich nicht so gut aus denn die
impfungen gehen immer weiter zurück die
impfkampagne geht steht hinter ihren
erwartungen
aktuell sind 40.000 350 menschen erst
geimpft zweit impfungen haben bei 82
1363 und 343
1512 musterungen auffrischungen erst
zweit und
auffrischungsimpfungen insgesamt
164 1097 1600 und 2